confie les surveillants de prison tout
au long de cette journée les crs sont
intervenus pour que les familles
puissent rendre visite au début afin de
ne pas aggraver la tension dans les
prisons cela n'a pas été possible
partout 300 experts européens réunis à
paris pour tenter d'endiguer l'invasion
des programmes de télévision américains
et japonais l'occasion pour nous de
fêter le 60e anniversaire de la création
de la télévision dont les inventeurs
sont français et anglais dans la nuit la
liberté le titre du prochain spectacle
de robert hossein histoire de la
résistance robert hossein et frédéric
dard qui a écrit les textes en direct
avec nous dans cette édition
non là monsieur bonsoir deux conflits
sont en attente ce week-end peugeot et
les prisons peugeot d'abord en l'absence
de nouvelles propositions du côté des
syndicats comme de la direction les
grévistes occupent toujours la forge de
l'usiné de mulhouse et les ouvriers en
grève à sochaux comme à mulhouse ont
reçu leur feuille de paye du mois de
septembre
amputé d' au moins la moitié de leur
salaire conséquence la solidarité s'est
organisée entre et autour des familles
des grévistes reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux françois jolly roger mode
charles ribeiro marié trois enfants
ouvriers en carrosserie chez peugeot
mulhouse 17 ans d'ancienneté et 17e jour
de grève ce matin dans la boîte aux
lettres sa fiche de paie du mois de
septembre
le sens profond
comment vous allez faire pour vivre le
mois qui vient j'ai devant la banque
pour faire un prêt
et il n'existait pas un qui avait pas de
problème ils étaient d'accord et
l'allemande j'ai décidé de castiel de
l'été rire de mes enfants pour en
récupérer une pause afin de contenir
toute façon je savais quand je m'étais
engagé et
chez dc des ordures
et puis il ya ces soutiens inattendus
cet ouvrier non grévistes de peugeot
venu sonner à la porte pour proposer son
aide j'ai dit à ma femme ça me fait mal
d'avoir un collègue un ami qui va avoir
un mois très difficile et que nous on
puisse vivre normalement
la femme de charles ribeiro elle aussi
soutient l'engagement de son mari
peugeot elle ya travaillé 14 ans avant
de démissionner il y à un peu plus d'un
an
j'ai démissionné parce que j'aime le
plus je peux plus rester je veux plus
travailler dans des conditions
et un japonais dédié il m'a mis sur un
post très dur j'ai dû à une mine hâlée
infiltrant filtrants en essence comme et
c'était un produit très nocifs et les
chefs d'equipe a dit je je je je voulais
me citer la comédie quoi et ensuite je
suis rentré nous met sa maman marie
pendant 21 jours et puis 34 jours j'ai
fait une fausse couche quoi ai-je père
du bébé
tout ça parce que le travail l'amène aux
conditions et puis il n'a pas dit à
l'ats ou bien on va dialoguer
ils ont vu le mécontentement de beaucoup
de gens là la majorité il ya donc
quelque chose à faire j'espère qu'ils le
feront
ce soir charles ribeiro est retourné à
la forge de l'usiné de mulhouse pour une
sixième nuit d'occupation
conflit des surveillants de prison ce
soir le ministre de la justice lance un
nouvel appel à la négociation le
secrétaire général du syndicat force
ouvrière majoritaire chez les gardiens
monsieur vialette vient de nous répondre
au téléphone qu'aucune discussion ne
s'engageraient avant que les révocations
de certains gardiens grévistes grévistes
pardon ne soit levée la crainte du
gouvernement pour ce week-end c'est que
les visites des familles aux détenus de
puisse avoir lieu dans de bonnes
conditions ce qui ajouterait on comprend
aisément à la tension qui règne déjà
dans les établissements pénitentiaires
tout au long de cette journée donc et
crs se sont efforcé d'assurer le libre
accès mais des incidents ont éclaté dans
deux villes au moins à angers et à la
roche sur yon reportage d'isabelle style
et luke savage
ils sont venus pour voir un proche et ne
savent pas encore s'ils pourront entrer
un patient ça freine les familles de
détenus ont dû attendre les parloirs ont
été assurés mais avec retard ici comme
dans 35 établissements pénitentiaires
les surveillants ont déposé les peler
seule une dizaine d'entre eux sont
encore en poste les crs assurent
désormais les tâches quotidiennes
il y avait un refus de
recevoir du linge et que les détenus
sont obligé de laver leur linge veux tu
ne reçois pas que le travail est très
mat et parce qu'habituellement nous ne
faisons pas celle que que de tant de
personnes c'est ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure j'ai dit qu on devra essayer de
ces sud d'arrêter ce conflit que les crs
étaient pas compétent pour remplacer les
gardiens a la preuve qu'il ya une
nervosité qui s'installe
stade de suspens taper dessus
aweys tape dessus comme thaler les gens
qui attendaient dehors ils se tapaient
c'était pascal papé dessus ça crée une
sacrée d'attention
situation plus tendue à epinal les
femmes il est éclater leur colère face
au piquet de grève devant l'entrée de la
prison les surveillants entendent est
ainsi bloqué les parloirs les forces de
l'ordre sont intervenues
à la roche sur yon la suppression des
parloirs a provoqué une mutinerie une
soixantaine de détenus ont saccagé
l'établissement d'un incident angers ce
soir tout est rentré dans l'ordre les
surveillants attendent maintenant la
levée des évocations près de 300 leur
ont été notifiées
mais au total 1500 demandes auraient été
envoyés à la chancellerie
depuis une semaine maintenant la classe
politique s'est emparé de ce conflit des
prisons et après la gauche et bien c'est
l'opposition qui demande à jacques
calvet le pdg de psa de négocier dans le
conflit peugeot déclaration faite ce
matin aux journées parlementaires du rpr
d'arcachon pas le secrétaire général du
mouvement alain juppé qui estime par
ailleurs que dans le conflit des prisons
et bien la politique du ministre de la
justice constitue une véritable
provocation monsieur juppé
le refus du dialogue est tout aussi
cassant au ministère des finances où les
inconséquences du patron fondé générer
un conflit social qui dure depuis des
mois que dire de la politique
provocatrices
et dangereuses
de monsieur arpaillange qui révoltent
créé 25 ans gardien de prison au moment
même où il prétend invité les syndicats
à s'asseoir autour de la table pour
discuter curieuse méthode pour nous
gaulliste le dialogue la concertation la
politique contractuelle permettent seul
de résoudre les conflits faire perdre la
face à l'une ou l'autre des parties
s'est créé pour l'avenir les conditions
d'un durcissement social auquel personne
mariée elle a gagné
20 tonnes de cocaïne découvertes dans un
entrepôt de los angeles c'est la plus
importante prise jamais réalisée par la
police américaine la drogue saisie était
en provenance de colombie livrée par le
fameux trop fameux cartel de medellin
contre lequel les états unis et le
gouvernement colombiens ont engagé une
véritable guerre ouverte véronique
taveau
coup d'éclat de la police de los angeles
et un coup sérieux porté aux trafiquants
américain 20 tonnes de cocaïne pure la
plus grosses saisies de l'histoire de la
drogue la cocaïne était stocké ici dans
cet entrepôt sur les paquets une
provenance qui ne fait aucun doute la
colombie les cartel de medellin et cali
une valeur estimée à 7 milliards de
dollars 45 milliards de francs vendu au
détail dans la rue le montant pourrait
atteindre 20 milliards de dollars un
joli coup de filet qui survient en
pleine guerre déclenchée contre les
trafiquants américains et colombiens un
coup de fil est d'autant plus réussie
que les policiers ont également mis la
main sur 10 millions de dollars en
liquide et sur des listes de noms parmi
eux les plus gros trafiquants du pays
spectaculaire également la démonstration
des autorités mexicaines 6 tonnes de
cocaïne détruite par carlos salinas en
personne un geste à la veille de la
visite du président mexicain washington
les américains reprochent un mexicain un
trop grand laxisme en matière de lutte
contre la drogue est demandée contrôle
plus ferme aux frontières
cette saisie de los angeles inscrits
dans le plan anti drogue lancée par le
président américain george bush pour
tenter de délivrer son pays d'un fléau
qui gagne chaque jour en importance
ainsi que le prouve le reportage que
vous allez voir toutes les grandes
villes américaines sont touchées en
effet bien entendu mêmes washington la
capitale fédérale n'est pas épargné
chaque fan semaine là-bas des drogués
viennent s'approvisionner et les
hôpitaux sont en état d' alerte pro
portage de notre correspondant jacquat
bouchard
le fin de semaine vendredi et samedi
soir sont les plus redoutés avec la
multiplication des règlements de pont
entre revendeurs et l'arrivée des
toxicomanes en état de choc ils ont fumé
soit du crac soit du pcp un
tranquillisant chimiques mélanger à la
marijuana
le grand manitou pour la drogue au 10
août général c'est le docteur walter
fagiht ancien médecin militaire il a
servi au vietnam il aime à répéter ici
une autre guerre et je suis sur la ligne
de front
depuis quelques semaines déclare le
docteur fagiht je constate une
diminution de cocaïne et une
augmentation du pcp il représente 30 à
40% des cas en rien moi la cocaïne le
crack toucher 90% des drogués
côté
entravée par des draps et des lanières
en caoutchouc au plus fort de la crise
qui a suivi l'absorption de pcp ce jeune
homme bâillonné mobilise une demi
douzaine de personnes
deux femmes policiers sont venus en
renfort pour aider médecins et
infirmiers à neutraliser le malade
la phase de réactions violentes de se
prolonger pendant plusieurs heures avec
des moments de répit suivie d'une
nouvelle prix
dont le docteur faig c'est la phase
critique celle où l'effet euphorisant
étant retombée l'usagé du crack ou du
pcp développe une nette tendance au
suicide
audi side général l'hôpital central de
washington il y avait eu 12 admission
due au crac l'accompagnent fumable en
1995 et 2000 288 soit 200 fois plus en
quatre ans la politique étrangère
maintenant pour tenter de consolider le
cessez-le-feu qui tient au liban depuis
une semaine les parlementaires libanais
sous l'égide des pays médiateurs de
ligue arabe sont réunis en ce moment
même en arabie saoudite 63 députés sur
73 chrétiens et musulmans qui vont
essayer de mettre au point un règlement
global du conflit libyen
la situation était devenue intenable à
l'intérieur de l'ambassade d'allemagne
fédérale à prague en tchécoslovaquie
3500 réfugiés venus d'allemagne de l'est
avaient envahi les jardins pendant que
d'autres continuent aujourd'hui samedi
de franchir les grilles se soit enfin la
visite du ministre ouest allemand des
affaires étrangères monsieur dietrich
genscher à débloquer la situation les
réfugiés pourront partir dès cette nuit
direction la bavière thierry calmette
la tante insupportable va prendre fin
dans les jardins de l'ambassade
d'allemagne fédérale à prague les 3500
réfugiés seulement manifestent
bruyamment vont ils pouvoir passer à
l'ouest ils réfugiés juché sur les
grilles près du bâtiment tout près pour
être les premiers à savoir et dans
l'après midi monsieur genser le ministre
des affaires étrangères de la république
fédérale arrivés avec la bonne nouvelle
dès ce soir et pendant toute la nuit
cinq trains spéciaux embarqueront hommes
femmes et enfants destination la bavière
l'ouest enfin
monsieur gensel revenait de new york où
il effectue une dernière tentative pour
accentuer la pression de l'opinion
occidentale sur la tchécoslovaquie dans
les jardins de l'ambassade la situation
devenait explosive sous les tentes en
nombre insuffisant les hommes ne dormait
plus qu'à tour de rôle un sommeil
difficile les puis transformé les
jardins en bourbier l'attention à la
fatigue atteignez le maximum désormais
c'est fini les 3500 allemands de l'est
se réfugier ici ils deviendront dès
demain matin de nouveaux citoyens
d'allemagne de l'ouest
en france remise de décorations à des
sapeurs pompiers de l'essonne ayant
participé aux secours après le
tremblement de terre en arménie l'hiver
dernier à cette occasion les pompiers
ont procédé à une démonstration mettant
en valeur leur technique dans bien
d'autres domaines que celui du
traditionnel combat contre l' incendie
reportage de marc maisonneuve et
stéphane poule
ces hommes sont des pompiers ici dans le
département de l'essonne il effectue une
intervention toutes les 8 minutes
leur quotidien a radicalement changé le
risque a évolué par exemple le feu
représente 13% des actions des
sapeurs-pompiers sa nature elle même
s'est modifiée chimiques elle produit
des fumées toxiques
l'eau n'est plus un agent extinct
savons qui est cantonné dans une image
un peu d'epinal de combattants du feu et
ont souhaité repositionner un peu le
rôle exact des sapeurs-pompiers savoir
un rôle tout azimut vis-à-vis du risque
d'être s'avéreront tu aujourd'hui c'est
être homme de tous les dangers et donc
il fallait qu'on puisse à travers une
démonstration de nos gestes quotidiens
directs de nos actions opérationnelles
présenter tout simplement ce qui est
vraiment aujourd'hui la menace en termes
de risque à travers quatre simulation
une volonté montré que les nouveaux
risques impliquent l'utilisation de
nouveaux moyens
la désincarcération d'une victime d'un
accident de la route le sauvetage est
victime d'un incendie
les sapeurs-pompiers maîtrise des
techniques complètement nouvelle elles
ont fait la preuve d'une efficacité
envier à mexico puis en arménie
avec une lance thermique le béton en
fusion lui-même et creusé afin de
permettre l'évacuation d'une éventuelle
victime une victime dont on a appris à
repérer la moindre manifestation
en essonne en 1988 les pompiers sont
intervenus 63 mille fois et ce n'était
pas pour des exercices de simulation
françois mitterrand inaugurant ce matin
les travaux de la conférence européenne
sur l'audiovisuel à paris a déclaré
c'est par l'audiovisuel que l'europe
pourra préserver son identité culturelle
en effet devant la multiplication des
chaînes de télévision il s'agit en vain
jusqu'à présent d'endiguer l'invasion
des programmes venus d'amérique ou du
japon l'occasion pour nous de rappeler
que la télévision a aujourd'hui 60 ans
et que ses inventeurs ont été anglais et
français en quête de stéphane magnier et
jean-françois cheveux
1929 l'homme un peu guindée qui pose au
milieu de ses collaborateurs s'appelle
john baird l'invention qu'il présente
des images animées transmises par ondes
simple curiosité de laboratoire pour
baird les toutes premières images de
télévision pour nous
télévision selon le doit à l'ingénieur
français barthélémy le premier à y avoir
vraiment cru mais comment aurait-il pu
l'imaginer ce destin en 60 ans les
premiers programmes réguliers
la première eurovision avec le
couronnement d'elizabeth 2
l'apparition de la couleur aujourd'hui
le satellite demain les écrans géants et
la haute définition
mais son virage de plus décisif a aussi
peut être été le plus discret la
télévision a pris une telle place dans
la vie de tous les jours quel est le
premier lieu d'expression des créateurs
elle est devenu le gardien des cultures
nationales
aujourd'hui que les télévisions privées
dévions commerciales ont envahi l'europe
on se rend compte
qui dit culture elle est menacée et que
donc à une véritable responsabilité à la
fois pour le gouvernement pour les
créateurs les producteurs tous ceux qui
font des images à s'occuper d'eux aussi
de ce qui se passe chez nous à dire en
europe dans nos différents pays d'europe
et à faire que la culture soit prise en
compte les chiffres sont éloquents il
existe sans des chaînes de télévision en
europe elles ont besoin de 125 mille
heures de programmes par an l'europe
n'en produit que 20000 tout le reste
c'est de l'importation essentiellement
des états unis si pour essayer d'enrayer
cette marée américaines que sont réunis
depuis ce matin les plus grands
professionnels de l'audiovisuel de 23
pays d'europe
trouver de l'argent s'associe à
plusieurs pays harmoniser les techniques
et les législations mais quelles que
soient les structures de production ou
les moyens de financement que va pouvoir
élaborer cette oreille car audio visuel
et voudra en puces résoudre un problème
particulièrement délicat à trouver un
terrain un langage commun à tous ces
pays dont l'histoire est faite dans leur
affrontement mutuelle et ce ne sera
certainement pas facile
georges ulmer vient de mourir à
marseille à l'âge de 70 ans des suites
d'une longue maladie pour les plus
jeunes d'entre nous disons qu'il fut
l'une des grandes vedettes de la chanson
de l'après guerre et qu'il crée un
succès qui a traversé le temps et les
frontières pigalle michelle wie
station de métro entouré de bichot payal
grand magasin à tenir matin au
restaurant couru liga
ces chanteurs des concours
tu peux donner sur ces deux jours
et six athlètes en maillot qui soulève
son
avec pigalle georges ulmer fait valser
la france d'après-guerre et sept
chansons traduites en huit langues rares
à l'époque le consacre vedettes
internationales
tout au long des allées 57 auteur
compositeur interprète
personnifie le chanteur de charme chacun
le fraudeur
et pourtant ce jeune danois exilé à nice
millions le nazisme voulait être boxeuse
grand bien pour lui pour nous qu'il
raccrochera les gants savez georges
ulmer la place pigalle acquis ses
lettres de noblesse
ces mannequins gitanos malades
king lisent dans les mains
c'est nous qui vous remercions monsieur
une mère
un spectacle comme les aime romero scène
grandiose réaliste du cinéma sur scène à
partir du 4 octobre au palais des sports
de la porte de versailles à paris dans
la nuit la liberté l'histoire de la
résistance française pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale en direct avec nous ce
soir robert hossein et frédéric dard
l'auteur des textes mais avant
présentation par georges bégoux est ivre
c'est un leurre de croire que les hommes
moyens ne sont capables que de
sacrifices moyens
bernanos
monsanto
geithner la traîne
htc nantes-info
d'entre nous
ah ben
oui
vous
avec nous qu'on donc en direct du palais
des sports de la porte de versailles
robert hossein en compagnie de georges
bigot avec frédéric dard robert hossein
une première question tout de suite
l'année dernière avec votre spectacle
sur la révolution c'était les grands
héros de la révolution qui était mise en
scène cette fois-ci ce sont les français
moyen les j'allais dire les les petits
résistant et non pas les grandes figures
de la résistance
alors daniel bilalian nous n'avons
absolument pas le retour sont mais je
devine à peu près la teneur de votre
question et je la pose directement à
robert o 5 daniel devez vous demander
pourquoi cette fois-ci vous vous êtes
attaqués de petites gens n'ont pas à des
héros de la révolution comme l'autre
fois
et moi même un hommage à tous les gens
qui sont morts
anonymes et qui n'ont pas leurs grands
noms
sur les frontons et qui ont étaient
d'une
d'un courage qui ont été prodigieux pour
l'heure la guerre et qui se sont battus
pour frauder pour leur dignité pour la
liberté
est ce que les héros ne sont pas tous
célèbrent en fait ça la résistance l'a
démontré l'héroïsme était à la portée si
j'ose dire de tous les courages et alors
robert a été hanté par cette idée depuis
déjà pas mal d'années et on a plongé
dans cette aventure justement
moi j ai plongé je vais vous dire j'ai
plongé en romancier en inventeur
d'histoire ne fabule ateurs en bonhomme
qui qui qui passe sa vie à essayer
d'intéresser les gens et j'ai voulu
cette fresque que robert avaient
édulcoré avait affiné etc il me l'a
confié et là dessus j'ai inventé des
histoires inventées j'ai mis si vous
voulez un mot qui peut être va vous
paraître bizarre la circonstance du
suspense donc ça se suit comme une pièce
assez semaine je pense mais je l'espère
mais c'est pas seulement une pièce parce
que lorient le spectacle se joue partout
dans tout le le palais et ses composants
plusieurs parties et il ya beaucoup de
décors dire et il ya dans le cadre d'un
personnage voilà exactement cas ça situe
en vitesse je le dis il y à un prologue
qui est un hommage à dix grands
résistants de la dernière guerre il ya
ensuite notre histoire à nous qui est la
première partie la préparation de la
mission la recherche de volontaires
puisqu'il ya un grand réseau qui est
guetté si je peux dire par les allemands
et il faut faire un réseau aujourd'hui à
l'instar dû constituer un faux résout
dans le vrai pour souci de servir
d'appât pour sauver lens est un argument
très fort en voilà et ensuite les
volontés à se dire on choisit les
volontaires et la première partie sur le
choix et la vie de ces volontaires et
qu'il son instituteur médecins comme
tous les gens quotidien avec leur coeur
leur problème et c est tout à coup ils
sont volontaires pour une mission et
tout à coup ils sont devant la mission
c'est la deuxième partie c'est l'action
et cette mission il s'attendait
absolument pas une seconde il n'était
pas du tout préparé pour la mission
d'action qu'il est
qui va se passer alors c'est plus que
leur histoire par rapport à cette
mission dont l'histoire de gens simples
affronter vraiment à des événements qui
les dépasse un peu ont réussi sont pas
préparés pour si vous voulez ce sont des
gens qui travaillent dans les villes qui
qui s'occupent elles sont pas des
résistants de mackinder existants
complètement préparé cet autre italien
il n'y a pas et il n'y a pas eu que je
sache de résistants professionnels non
je veux dire que c'est quand même une
jamais d'années on l'est devenu à cause
des circonstances résistants moi je suis
j'ai côtoyé ça moi même j'étais jeune
mais enfin j'ai j'ai reniflé la
résistance gym j'ai tué dans l'est
lyonnais gt gt à lyon donc avec au parmi
des résistants et j'ai senti monter
croître cette espèce d'éloge espèce de
philosophie de patriotisme en treillis
même de patriotisme pattern je vais te
patriotisme viscéral c'est pas du tout
monter sur les barricades en brandissant
un drapeau c'est quelque chose de l'an
de sourds comme ça qu'ils qui se fait
qu'ils se tisser avec le recul on dit
c'était la règle c'est pour ça qu'on dit
cette phrase nous qui résume tout le
spectacle c'est un leurre de croire que
les hommes moyens ne sont capables que
de sacrifices moyens s'il n'est pas bien
mais ne voient leur mairie donc le 15 06
nov dans très peu de temps vous êtes
bref j'espère un autre du tout mais
robert n'est jamais prêt là mais moi je
vous tous pour un mois il vous dira de
confiance messieurs merci on va vous
laisser discuter ensemble parce que nous
n'avons pas terminée donc à partir du 4
octobre au palais des sports de la porte
de versailles un message du président de
la république monsieur françois
mitterrand ce soir au grand rabbin de
france monsieur sitruk à l'occasion du
nouvel an juif le chef de l'état adresse
ses voeux de bonheur et de prospérité à
la communauté juive de france
journée nationale pour l'adoption des
animaux organisé aujourd'hui par tous
les refuges de la fondation de la
fondation assistance aux animaux autant
de chiens et de chats abandonnés par les
propriétaires inconscients qui n'ont pas
compris que ces animaux n'étaient pas
des jouets mais des compagnons dont il
faut assumer la charge 24 heures sur 24
reportage de denise bauer et clémence
again
article 1er tous les animaux naissent
égaux devant l'asie et ont les mêmes
droits à l'existence
article 6 tout animal que l'homme a
choisi pour compagnon a droit à une
durée de vie conforme à sa longévité
naturel l'abandon d'un animal est un
acte cruel et dégradant
de milliers de chiens et de chats
abandonnés 14 derrière des barreaux
demain c'est leur fête et tout le monde
veut faire quelque chose article 3 nuls
animal ne sera soumis à des mauvais
traitements ni à des actes cruels con
surtout réfléchir qu'un chien un chat ou
la docte aux dix quinze vingt ans donc
il faut être conscient que c'est une vie
et donc que réflexion avant donc pas de
coup de coeur mais à une bonne
répétition pour éviter que cet animal
qu'on adopte aujourd'hui on l'a donc
brandon demain déjà des animaux de
compagne non pas du tout donc c'est la
première fois et pourquoi qu'est ce qui
a déclenché chez vous il envie d'en
avoir
un point comme je suis seul parce que ça
fait une bonne compagnie
article 2 tout animal a droit au respect
à la tension aux soins et à la
protection de l'homme extrait de la
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'animal
les hommes aussi ce week end à
saint-ouen l'aumône dans le val d'oise
une manifestation intitulée mémorial
coluche est organisé pour récolter des
fonds permettant cette année encore
l'ouverture des restos du coeur le sport
paradoxale la situation d'alain prost
avant le grand prix d'espagne de formule
1 de demain qui pourrait d'ores et déjà
le consacré champion du monde 89 avant
même d'atteindre la fin de la saison et
bien au lieu d'être entouré et choyés le
champion français est isolé au sein de
son écurie mclaren honda qui doit
quitter l'année prochaine pour ferrari
demain alain prost partira en troisième
position derrière son coéquipier sénat
et bergen surfera sur place nous ont
envoyés spéciaux lionel chamoulaud aux
éclats
alain prost seul contre tous le pense
est largement leader du championnat du
monde et pourtant moralement il vit une
situation très difficile cette fois
clairement mclaren a choisi senna à
toute l'attention de l'équipe poste est
considéré et traité comme second pilote
sur le plan moral cette date un déficit
dans son enfance se sent complètement
complètement laissés pour compte dans
une équipe un pilote de formule un
marché avant tout au moral quand on a
fait 10 en formule 1
on ne peut pas se surpasser tous les
jours à essayer de
contrecarrer les problèmes des problèmes
que les autres nous pose deux conditions
de deuxième pilote chez mclaren quoi
pourtant dès demain alain prost pourrait
être champion du monde il lui suffit
d'une victoire ou que senna ne soit pas
sur le podium ou en cas de victoire du
brésilien une troisième place serait
suffisante pour le penser c'est la
course qui décidera ayrton senna est au
mieux en qualifications encore une fois
40e pole position du brésilien la 11e de
la saison magnifique
à ses côtés en première ligne berg
guerre et sa ferrari
l'autrichien petit exprimer totalement
demain lorsque l'on sait qu'il
remplacera prote l'année prochaine chez
mclaren sans fait sous les casques à
jerez mais demain tout pourrait être
joué et ce suspense malsain terminée moi
je suis beaucoup moins de ministres
concernant chacun des manques
que la majorité des gens et
je me je verrai ce qui se passe alors je
pense même pas au championnat pour
l'espagne
je pense à peine pour le trafic voici la
grille de départ de ce grand prix
d'espagne coup de chapeau a suivi palio
qui réussit une magnifique cinquième
place avec ça la route allez-y et 9e
brouillard 24e a renoué raffanel ne se
sont pas qualifiés
plus calme le tiercé qui s'est couru cet
après-midi tiercé et quarté + discours
est à evry voilà les résultats qui vont
s'inscrire sur votre écran pour gagner
il fallait jouer le 11 2 et le 12 et
pour ce qui concerne le quarté + et bien
ajouté le sis à ses trois premiers
numéros pour gagner un petit peu plus de
22000 fou voilà tout de suite après
journal laurent cabrol et les prévisions
météo après cela michel drucker qui
reçoit qui reçoit ce soir un invité
exceptionnel puisqu'il s'agit du
commandant cousteau beaucoup de
reportages et puis une interview choc du
commandant cousteau aux alentours de
23h30 vous retrouverez philippe gassot
pour les toutes dernières informations
quant à nous si vous voulez bien on se
retrouve demain à 13 heures précises
bonsoir bonne soirée sur notre chaîne
hop